a sham and a violation of the U.N
Charter is what NATO calls the
referendums on annexing four Russian
occupied regions of Ukraine describing
it as a sign of weakness after losses on
the battlefield NATO says it will ignore
the outcome and continue to give Ukraine
Military Support what we should do we
should get all the countries together
that have for instance the leopard tank
and see that we joined forces train
together sent leopards together to
Ukraine in which they need right now if
they want to
succeed in
reconquering the territory that Russia
has under occupation so far the German
government has been reluctant to send
battle tanks fearing that President
Vladimir Putin would consider it a
provocation but analysts say these
referendums show that NATO has not
managed to deter Putin from annexing
regions in eastern Ukraine covering an
area the size of Portugal would you call
it a failure by NATO
on the one hand yes
on the other hand you could also say
that NATO has been successful in
avoiding a Russia NATO War which has
always been one of NATO's
major aims
so I
would say it depends on on your
perspective for Ukraine it makes the
situation more difficult yes refugees
continue to arrive in Germany Hannah and
Osan came from Asia one of the regions
where the vote is being held in spite of
fierce fighting I think that is the
biggest mistake and it shouldn't be at
all on my territory where Ukrainian and
we don't need Russian people at all on
my country we are very angry and
we don't understand why another world
can be a little aggressive to Russia
I think they're doing not enough yes not
enough
more than one million Ukrainian refugees
have arrived in Germany and European
governments are preparing for more to
come as the war escalates and Russia
mobilizes hundreds of thousands of
reservists not only ukrainians but also
Russians are expected to come now
Germany says that those who refuse to
fight can apply for Asylum
a fight with no end in sight these
people don't know if it will be weeks
months or years before they can go home
stop fasten Al Jazeera Berlin